Electronic Arts had an earnings call
earlier today we know and what you kids
love them numbers so we got Justin hey
Walt gamespot News chief czar editor
gentlemen my title is just gentlemen
gentlemen gentlemen Justin hey Walt
yesterday world and master can you tell
us all about the earnings call so what
goodies have they thrown at for us
earnings calls are really boring but
this is that earnings period because
it's the end of the fiscal year which is
always a little bit confusing but you
know the numbers period the for toxic
purposes that ends now so what yes yes
sure business time and in business guys
get together and they do a lot of buzz
work okay yeah that's a lot of cocaine
yeah and they're real boring but we find
it somewhere sorry so that you don't
have to listen to it so that I don't
have to sit through a really boring call
we have our guys we're listening in on
this and they will sometimes give us a
presentation before hand on a PDF or
what they're going to be talking about
in this case that the presentation is
going on right now we're still listening
so there could be some cool okay news
that leaks out like the the highlight is
always if they say something are not
supposed to like if they are like oh and
yeah also Mirror's Edge 3 is going to be
whoa whoa whoa but mayor's edge to
hasn't even come out yet exactly because
what we did see today is we got kind of
a date for the next Mirror's Edge and
for a new plants vs zombies game okay I
mean we knew these well we knew who murs
edge is coming look right there where we
also a confirmation of FIFA 15 or 16
madden 16 NHL 16 and of course Roy
McElroy PGA Tour bye bye tiger coming q
2 ndlife 16 Need for Speed more need for
you need for speed TBA yeah which is of
the world looking forward to a star wars
battlefront of course but yeah q4
looking really interesting their new
mirrors edge TV of course since for the
battle arena yeah some oba so if your
speed MOBA even though that's you know
for as far as Need for Speed
announcements goes an interesting mobo
pretty that's uh so even though that
says 24 that's not coming at the end of
this year that's gonna be this period so
that's from january till the end of
march 2016 [ __ ] disco before you know
it by the
of this fiscal year which is by the
beginning of 2016 we should get the new
mirrors edge and a new plants vs zombies
and this one's listed for console and PC
so anything we can make a guess about
what that would be so probably a garden
warfare 2 as opposed to a desktop no I
mean it could be it could be maybe
plants vs zombies 2 coming to console
and PC because did it ever come to PC
was always a mobile never did so it
could be that yeah or or Cabela's
probably yeah it's probably our garage
it's probably dansgame garden warfare 2
is or gran amor for one was pretty good
game yeah all things considered a bunch
yeah fun it was and it's taken a long
fun time for us to get Mirror's Edge I
can't believe like that was announced a
while ago yeah yeah that logo was just
the mirrors edge logo is there any
chance this is just like Haley Dutton HD
release this up I mean or do we have
more concrete information on no this is
a different game I just hope so like
especially when you think about the the
gears of war information that came at a
couple day or last week but more HD
re-release is coming from as a black
tusk like Mirror's Edge 2 is like the
worst kept secret in games development
history is it a stock homes it's where X
dice guys a lot of them or those guys
involved there I remember there's an
interview a couple of years ago about
them having an in-development there was
no confirmation and eventually they
confirmed it and eventually put this
trailer out but we've seen nothing since
so presumably they've been making it for
a long time just on the side or
something it's again that's easy to be
scared about because I know it was
critically well-received and it was
really it was a lot of fun but didn't
tell me to give that her cell no it
didn't sell well so it was a it was a
big surprise we're like oh you're making
a new mirrors edge and like this is
awesome hopefully they're still there so
gonna make it it's not gonna be you know
yours edge one we already have that
built might as well just gonna major
changes you think they're gonna make to
try to Goose the sales on this one or
are they just gonna rely on like that
cult status then catapulting them to the
next yeah like hopefully it's had enough
of like gestation period by three years
or whatever a long five years of people
talking about because the problem was
like I often felt like they put that the
shooting part which was the worst part
of that game in just to have it in for
traitors or something just to show that
there was like you know something else
that happens in this the part
I have is that when Mirror's Edge came
out that was very much a the time when
like when portal came out it was like oh
you can make first-person games that
aren't about shooting and like we're
past that we're like a past a post gone
home world of post dear Esther world
where like first-person games and orange
shooters are actually kind of par for
the course by now like what would you
want in a new mirrors edge but then
seeing that world in HD would still be a
lot of fun like that that was there is
hasn't been another parkour like a game
that's just purely I'm running and
jumping up buildings and along walls
that feels that free my we had a park
where I'm on set a lot of Game seven but
ranked titanfall yeah and uh the zombie
game recently the shooting so wait on
you i dying i am sure i feel like the
closest we've come to like this kind of
movement whoa Vaughn I mean yes I love
titanfall on the wall running there but
dishonored with the blink ability like
that created like that basically made it
a first-person platformer in a way that
like not met very many other games have
done as well and because of that
teleport ability and the ques it gave
you so I don't and like that just made
moving through those levels a much more
fascinating puzzle so that's what I'm
kind of open for from Mirror's Edge that
but then again this fluidity that
they're sort of demonstrating that's
always been there things so kind of
measured like I'm gonna teleport here
and then zip over here is a little
slower pace than Mirror's Edge aims to
be hmm yeah fingers crossed they can do
sort of what portal 2 did off portal one
was a sequel that people were thinking
like what can they possibly do to mix up
this new formula and they ended up doing
a pretty good job and having a cool
dystopian world like there's there's a
lot of interesting story stuff left to
explore it yeah alright well guess we'll
have to see over the hopefully we'll see
some of the 83 perhaps especially if
we're looking to plan to release a q1 of
next year I just enable thank very much
for coming in let us know if anything
else is happening on the earnings call
right now I'm gonna go stay right there
alright sounds good
you